maintenant frédéric qui dit nouveau
parlement dit aussi reflet de la société
canadienne vous avez comme jc certaines
données pour nous il y aura des élus de
tous les âges dans ce nouveau parlement
oui on peut commencer par vraiment le
côté extrême c'est à dire le doyen de
cette chambre des communes c'est louis
plamondon le frère de l'ue plamandon le
parolier bloquiste il était élue en 1984
ça fait 35 ans déjà à l'époque c'était
sous la bannière des conservateurs de
brian mulroney et donc il va entamer son
11e mandat à l'âge de 76 ans par contre
à l'opposé on a aussi les jeunes qui
rentrent et notamment ce jeune
conservateur de kenora c'est dans le
nord de l'ontario eric mairie l'eau il a
tout juste 21 ans mais attention c'est
pas le record céline en fait le record
il faut remonter en 2011 avec ce jeune
néo démocrates à sherbrooke évidemment
qui détient le record absolu pierre luc
dusseault à l'époque il avait été élu à
l'âge de 19 ans et 11 mois
il ya aussi des jeunes femmes qui font
leur rentrée notamment deux femmes de 25
ans d'abord la bloquiste christina
michaud ça c'est du côté de matane et de
la gaspésie des îles de la madeleine
elle a 25 ans et puis elle assoit
collègue néo-démocrate mobile ac kaka
c'est la députée néo-démocrate du
nunavut et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'elle a 25 ans et c'est à peu près
l'âge moyen de la population qu'elle va
représenter ou inavoués
et justement les femmes prennent un peu
plus de place dans ce nouveau parlement
oui céline mais c'est vraiment asselain
regardez plutôt si on compare les
élections depuis 2011 regardez on est à
peu près à 24 7% monte à 26 28 qu'a donc
on est encore très très loin évidemment
de la fameuse parité dont 96 femmes sur
338 sièges
ce sont les libéraux qui ont non plus
avec 50 ensuite eh bien vous avez les
conservateurs le bloc québécois le npd
les verts et une indépendante évidemment
c'est jodie wilson route une autochtone
autochtone mais les autochtones demeure
assez faible assez faiblement représenté
effectivement en fait il y avait
soixante candidats autochtones qui se
sont présentés seulement 10 ont été élus
c'est comme en 2015 voici la répartition
il y en a trois en colombie-britannique
de au manitoba et le reste vous voyez ça
sur répartis un peu partout avec une
majorité de candidats libéraux qui ont
été élus sous l'étiquette en fait en
étant autochtone donc c'est faible mais
c'est constant pour l'instant
merci pour ces chiffres avant rowling